so this talk is called a history of
programming languages for two voices
this is an actually an idea that Mike
and I came up with over a year ago we
wanted to do it at the last strange loop
but for various reasons it didn't happen
till this time but we're really excited
to present this talk it's something that
leaves we kind of got together we both
have a very deep love of programming
languages but we're also really we're
musicians but we're also sort of music
connoisseurs so to speak so we thought
it'd be cool to do basically it's kind
of like a mixtape about the sort of the
chronology of programming languages
along with interesting things that were
happening in music around the same time
and kind of like a mixtape we're kind of
juxtaposing things you might not even be
clear exactly how these things are
related but hopefully it'll create maybe
maybe interesting ideas and it'll be a
lot of fun so a little bit about myself
before you get started my name is David
Nolan I am the lead developer of
clojurescript I also work a soft I'm a
software engineer at cognitive I work on
day Tomic which is a immutable
relational database hi I'm Mike
Bernstein I'm a amateur computer
scientist and record collector work for
a company called code climate that's
based in New York City it's a hosted
static analysis platform and we should
get started like David said one thing
this talk is not as comprehensive right
so in the same way that you probably
wouldn't like yell at your high school
boyfriend for making you a mixtape that
didn't have like every single song on
every single album on it don't don't
expect more than what you see up here
we're really excited to present to you
today and a little bit like two seconds
of off script I just wanted to take an
opportunity to really thank Alex Miller
for putting this conference together and
all the organizers and particularly for
inviting last night's closing keynote to
speak the issues that were addressed in
that talk are extremely personal
important to David and I and we were
saying before yesterday that this is our
this is our favorite conference and
having something like that here really
nailed at home so onto the talk the talk
is thanks
so we've divided the talk into a few
different sections you know the history
of music is much longer than the history
of programming languages and so since
this is our idiosyncratic mixtape we
decided to start in a section that we
call the roots and the roots of computer
science that we decided to start with
we're in around the mid 1930s or so and
this is where we're going to begin our
journey and David's gonna start us off
so part of the reason why we were
starting sort of in the 1930s is that I
mean if you if you really look at the
history of computing I mean there's so
much around mathematics and logic but it
really was into the 20th century when
people started kind of computable theory
that the fact that computers could even
be constructed and that software was
actually gonna happen that computing
really took off it's very much a 20th
century phenomenon computers but in this
similar way something happened to music
are on the same time and this was the
ability to record music onto some
physical thing and distribute that music
prior to the 20th century you really
couldn't you know experience music
without either being able to perform it
yourself or being in the presence of a
performer and I think it's easy to see
that music I mean music has always been
an extremely important part of human
life but you've seen it explode in a way
that I don't think anybody could have
predicted thanks to recorded music so so
so you know for the for the computer
science stuff I mean you could pick a
lot of places to start but we we're both
fans of functional programming and this
is such a huge paper this is where
Alonzo Church was sort of thinking about
computability and he's sort of on the
side invents this thing called the
lambda calculus and you know that will
trigger all a massive you know
development in theory but as well as
something that that people couldn't have
imagined you know 30 almost 30 years
after this somebody would create a
programming language which would use the
lambda calculus as its foundation so you
know this is the beginning of a very big
bang we like to say the lambda calculus
you may have heard of it
so that we picked this this record it's
a really cool record this is a
collection of pieces by 20th century
composers quite a few interesting people
in on this one the one we're gonna play
for you is olivier messiaen
he was a serial composer but he really
loved birdsong and he wrote pieces
specifically for this new type of
instrument and it was a kind of like a
theremin but it had keys and had a very
to me a very twentieth-century sound
it's electronic it's something that
people really hadn't heard before we're
gonna play you a short clip of this
so the reason why we chose that is David
said is that that doesn't sound like
music that would have been composed in
the early 19th alright in the early 20th
century to me anyway so having an
individual that composes music start to
look for other other media through which
to express their sound was a really
profound and interesting thing to us and
their echoes and what they had said
about programming languages in this
music and we're gonna play one more
piece from the same time period roughly
this is music by Pierre Honore that he
composed with his mentor Pierre
Schaeffer in France and and they
invented a genre of ostensibly
contemporary classical music called
music concrete so they take this idea of
using pure electronic media to express
music even further by removing all
instrumentation from music and composing
only with tape so most people conceive
of the idea of sampling as being you
know a late 19th 20th 20th century
phenomenon but in fact these gentlemen
in suits and very serious faces in the
1930s and 1940s we're making music that
a lot of people might take issue with
calling it music so let's hear
variations on a door and a sigh and the
reason why it has that title will be
very clear
comedic timing so the that is a piece of
music composed of the sound of a door
kind of creaking and a person signing
and they took these pieces of they took
these samples on a magnetic tape and
manipulated them in all these different
ways and from that they made their
composition and you know this leads us
right into the next section that we call
reinvention and the idea for this
section and reinvention came from that
you know it from the from the between
the early 1940s in the mid 1950s you
know actual computers were invented
right so you had like actual machines
that people could program things on it
wasn't a very pleasant experience to
program them but by the time we get to
this period we see people taking the
actual material of computation and
thinking hmm I wonder if there's a
different way that we can do that and
we're gonna start this section off with
a quote from an interview with John
Backus one of the inventors of the
Fortran the inventor of the Fortran
programming language programming
language excuse me and he said I really
didn't know what the hell I wanted to do
with my life I decided that what I
wanted was a good hi-fi set because I
liked music in those days they didn't
really exist it's interesting that he
wanted one if they didn't really exist
so I went to a radio technician school I
had a very nice teacher the first good
teacher I ever had and he asked me to
cooperate with him and compute the
characteristics of some circuits for a
magazine so he kind of fell backwards
into computing and as you'll see he
didn't find it to be a particularly
pleasant experience as you see in this
quote from the same interview in 1953
frustrated by his experience of
hand-to-hand combat with the machine
Backus was eager to somehow simplify
programming he wrote a brief note to his
superior asking to be allowed to head a
research project with that goal I
figured there had to be a better way he
said and and we think this is still true
right and this is one of the themes of
this talk there's always we think going
to be a better way
and so he made a better way it was
called Fortran and this is the this is
the front page of the Fortran manual
designed to run on the IBM 704 in 58 59
or something like that and here you have
a high-level programming language
designed for scientific computation that
allowed people to actually use things
like abstraction in order to express
algorithms and programs so this is that
reinvention that we're talking about and
we're gonna and we're gonna hear about
two more languages that were created
around the same time that similarly
harnessed this desire to program
computers and not necessarily fistfight
with them so shortly after Fortran
appeared John McCarthy invented Lisp
that was in 57 this is a page from the
list one programmers manual unstated
March 1st 1960 and this is actually a
manual that talks about Lisp 1 to run on
the IBM 704 right so this was the
promise of compilers create you know
generating the assembly code for a
particular hardware was actually
happening people could program in
higher-level languages at a higher level
of abstraction and and get something
done what's fascinating about this is
that you know two compilers or in this
case an interpreter with some sort of
runtime still the idea was a common
desire to a high level program but so
different in their manifestation write
Fortran was about technical computing
like calculation and Lisp was created by
a sort of a mathematician logician and
he wanted to something very different
which was a symbolic mathematics
specifically to pursue this thing that
he was calling artificial intelligence
shortly thereafter and in a couple more
years a bunch of smart people got
together and they created Algol 60 and
in the shadow of Algol 60 is you know
vast almost everyone programs in some
dialect of Algol 60 it's the most
popular a sort of dialect that exists
today so when we were sitting around
talking about what what you know what
what music should we pick that that
makes sense there has some sort of
relationship to this period of time and
we and we sort of settled on jet the
sort of jazz movement in the 50s and the
reason we did
because in the same way that computing
it already existed for good 30 years
right the idea of computing the theory
of computing actual computers and
programming languages this was happening
and and the compiler thing and the
interpreter thing really sort of you
know allowed computing to become sort of
kind of free jazz have been around for
forty thirty years already but in this
period a bunch of talented individuals
decided to distill jazz into a very you
know pure essence and I think might get
some more things to say about yeah so
we're gonna play you a sample from
pianist named felonious monk who's often
considered one of the greatest jazz
pianists and composers of all time and
in fact was one of the progenitors of
this new style of jazz called bebop and
than hard bop and post Bob and all those
kinds of things so this is what we
wanted to what we want you to listen to
in this music if you don't know jazz and
you've never heard it before
just listen to the piano listen to the
rhythm of the piano and the way that the
piano is interacting with the music this
is a live recording from the five spot
in New York City and it's a tune called
in walked bud that felonious monk wrote
and dedicated to his pal Bud Powell this
is one of my favorite pieces of music
so something it's you have another penis
but very very different in Cecil Taylor
so Mike and I are both lucky enough to
have actually seen Cecil Taylor perform
in New York Cecil Taylor was really
somebody of the 60s and 70s but he
started in the in the in the sort of
bebop scene in New York City what's
interesting about the way that he plays
that it's it's very percussive its he
was really a big figure in what's called
the free jazz movement which was a
distinctly African American intellectual
sort of sort of event that happened
which is fantastic
most people know owner Coleman not as
many people know Cecil Taylor what's
what's really cool about his music it's
it's so it's so much distinctly his own
thing yet it's still jazz again you'll
hear that it's very dissonant a very
rhythmic very percussive you know it's
almost like he's drumming the pianos
all right thanks Cecil so the next
section we call this for the people it's
a shorter section but we wanted to
bridge the gap between the late 50s and
early 60s and you know the sort of some
of the more obvious benchmarks that
happen in the late 60s and early 70s so
in the mid 1960s you see a movement
where populism and popular culture
really starts to like take hold in a
really interesting way especially in the
United States so we're gonna see an
example of one programming language that
we feel fits this bill and then a piece
of music as well and David's gonna talk
about basic so a lot of things happen in
the 60s we're only gonna focus on this
one because I think it drives a really
just an important point home which was
an attempt to expand the number of
people that could get asked access to
the power of computing we found this
this is a basic user manual from October
1964 and the introductory paragraphs and
this is incorrect is really incredible
while Fortran might be great if you're a
scientist and list might be great if
you're logician there are lots of tasks
that computers can help humans
accomplish that don't require that level
of sophistication and the beginning of
the of this manual basically says almost
anybody can pick this up you know you
can look at this manual you know spend
about a week and you're really build to
get it and the truth is I know there's a
probably a lot of you in the audience
that probably learned basic when you
were children right basic is simple
enough for a child to pick up and I
think to this day people are constantly
looking at ways to widen the scope of
people who have access to the power of
computation so this is why I sort of
thought basic is the language of the
people and Mike's gonna talk about the
music selection yeah so there's a lot of
amazing music from this period of time
but one one thing that we couldn't
ignore was Motown so in the mid 1960s
you have a movement that starts in
Detroit based around a record label and
and this is one of the this is one of
those record labels that has a sound
right these producers and and musicians
and songwriters collaborated to make
something new right to make a from the
ground up new sound that ended up being
one of the most important and enduring
popular music movements ever right I
think everyone loves Motown music and
one of my favorite Motown tracks is
Martha and the Vandellas heatwave and
it's okay to dance to the song if you if
you have to
alright so the next section
it's called feed your head we're moving
into you know the psychedelic 60s there
was a lot of civil unrest all around the
world people were questioning you know
the way that society was organized
really sort of shaking things up you see
a similar thing happening in computer
science people had people had lived now
with programming language for quite a
bit of time and people were starting to
really go back and revisit some of these
assumptions and early designs there's a
very famous paper by landon called the
next 700 programming languages and it's
really sort of looking at you know while
we understand that high-level
programming is very effective it became
clear that even when you have a
high-level programming language there
can be flaws in the design there can be
problems with the semantics he refers to
something in this paper called ice swim
which will in many ways be the spiritual
predecessor to things like Miranda and
Haskell so you get a sense that that
people are looking in for something new
a lot of people started working on doing
new things Alan Kay at Xerox PARC
invented this language called small talk
which also ended up having a very long
shadow its early incarnation though was
was far more radical than how the small
talk ad ended up a small talk was a
language that was designed to be
oriented around many things that people
had never experienced before number one
the idea of a personal computer the fact
that on a personal computer could be
networked and I could communicate with
another human being that graphics would
be a fundamental primitive in the in the
computing interaction and you know
really wild ideas here around whether
sort of an iconic principle in the
language might have some power really
cool stuff and then you also had things
like Elaine comer Al and his group they
created something called Prolog right up
to this time people were writing
imperative algorithms and really sort of
instructing the computers step by step
what needed to be done but the Prolog
had the
totally radical idea where you make a
series of declarative statements and
then a search algorithm will be applied
to find the solution Prolog has this
really beautiful quality if your program
is pure it's actually possible to run
your program in both directions and to
do things like inference really crazy
stuff I think even to this day we still
haven't come to terms of the full
psychedelic potential of declarative
programming so these are some drawings
these are drawings that Elaine Kumar
made sort of describing how Prolog works
I like them because they just look like
art pretty crazy so something to kick
off is a band that I'm sure everybody's
heard of Pink Floyd everybody sort of
Pink Floyd I'm not sure I me people have
heard the early stuff that included Syd
Barrett and so we thought a good tune to
kick off this section is Lucifer Sam off
their first record
trencher
young
something I can't explain
all right that's it in the middle there
so one thing that we wanted to make sure
that we got across in this talk is that
there's something really obvious and
limiting in a way about the history of
programming languages in programming
language theory which is that they all
kind of came from people with very
similar backgrounds in very similar
situations trying to solve very similar
problems and a cool thing about music as
David noted earlier in the talk is that
it's universal right and a cool thing
about the 1960s is that this culture
will change the see change that was
happening was not only happening in the
United States it was happening all over
the world and there were amazing
cultural socio-political movements that
were consuming countries in Europe and
South America and Africa and everywhere
and one of my favorite instances of that
was in Brazil there was a
socio-political artistic movement called
tropic alia and at the forefront of that
was a band called Os Mutantes this is
one of my favorite tracks from one of my
favorite records of theirs and and what
I want you to think about is that you
know this uses the same substance and
this it's made up of the same stuff that
Pink Floyd is right this is essentially
the same instrumentation although it's
sung in a different language to express
a very different purpose toward a very
different end and and we just think that
that's beautiful and so we wanted to
share this with you to remind you that
there's a lot to be gained when you seek
perspectives outside of the narrow scope
of what you're typically exposed to
so here's Hospitality's the mutants
we've listened to these samples so many
times this next one is I think when when
Mike again women got together to plan
this talk out you know we have we share
a lot of of the similar tastes we also
have different tastes but one thing we
agreed upon was this record 1969 if your
record collector is one of the most
amazing years ever in the history of
recorded music but this is a record I'm
sure that you've probably never heard of
this is Sonny sherek he's often
categorized as a jazz musician though I
think the type of music he did was far
more powerful than that we're gonna play
you a track it's called a portrait of
Linda all in three colors all black do
you have anything else to say about this
track I can't believe we're showing this
to this audience and we're gonna play
them this right now I'm so excited so
not much else to say just enjoy
so nothing happened in the 70s we're not
gonna talk about semies so we're
skipping to the 80s yeah because we can
it's our mixtape make your own you like
the 70s it's cool make your own so the
eights of the 80s I think are sort of
remembered for rampant commercialism I
think Mike and I we both love of pop
music I mean you know Michael Jackson
Madonna Cyndi Lauper that stuff is great
but what was cool I think about the 80s
is that really I it was happened in the
mid 70s really but the beginning of what
you could call independent music and
underground music what was happening in
a similar way that computing was
becoming very cheap the materials
required to record a record was also
becoming cheap and artists could take
the matters into their own hands
so we're gonna focus first on some
languages that we think are we're
underground and what's interesting about
what's what's once underground often
becomes mainstream or is a far bigger
influence than anybody could imagine and
I think these programming languages
really fit this idea so the first of
those we're gonna talk about is language
called Miranda developed by David Turner
this is a paper from September 1985 and
it's called Miranda a non strict
functional language of polymorphic types
and some of us write code in programming
languages that still don't have access
to these features right so as David said
this is an idea that ended up having a
very long shadow
what's cool about Miranda is that it's
lazy it's a pure functional programming
language and it was the predecessor of
the spiritual direct predecessor to
Haskell programming language that we
both love and it is just incredible to
see at this time the the sort of nascent
form of these ideas that a programmer
interacting with a computer could get a
lot of assistance from the computer and
writing programs and could lean on a
type system and think about things like
referential transparency and its impact
on your ability to express programs so
we really
to choose this because it's a language
that not a lot of people know about and
one that you should check out if you
want to know where some of the roots of
some of these languages that you may
hear about a lot come from Miranda is a
big inspiration to those and next we
have here the Joe Armstrong was kind
enough to tweet this the other day this
is the first page of the script for ER
Lang the movie and so and yeah what up
Joe
so Erlang is another amazing really
interesting programming language that
still struggles with its underground
nests in a way right but the reason why
I wanted to bring it up here is because
I think what's so amazing about it is
that it's designed for a very specific
purpose right it's a language that was
designed for a particular domain and it
did it really well or actually it does
it really well right still doing it
Erickson where this language is invented
still employs this language to run its
telecommunication systems with 99 point
and nines uptime hot code reloading
functions modules and a lot of things
that again you don't see in other
programming languages right and it's
just this really interesting thing we're
born out of the desire to solve a very
specific problem a very specific and a
very successful solution was created and
and though there are still some sort of
specific purpose programming languages
today like this this to me is one that
really stands out and Earling it's a
really cool program in language that
we're also fans of so for this section
we picked some things that you're
unlikely to hurt anything except for
maybe the last one
the first thing is Jane's blood Elmer he
was he worked with Ornette Coleman he
has this really one of the coolest
things about his guitar style is the
only place was this thumb
this is his band that he put together
this record this recording has like you
can you can find this in a dollar banner
and I don't totally recommend picking it
up it's awesome dollar bands iTunes have
$1 right you could probably get this for
three bucks yes it's a weird record it's
like it's like it's like funk its soul
the R&B Punk
I mean it's all
mixed into this crazy thing very short
clip
and the next thing mics in time yeah so
toward the end of bands that were
influential but that a lot of people may
have never heard of this event called
suicides this is a band that was around
in the early 80s in New York one of
those records that you definitely didn't
want your parents to find in your
bedroom when you're a teenager because
then they're gonna ask you a lot of
questions about the name of the band and
the violent cover but this is a really
cool record because it's two people Alan
Alan Vega and Martin Rev and they're
trying to make a new sound they're in a
time in place where there's a lot very
interesting music happening the end of
disco the around the time of like
post-punk movement punk had sort of been
in full swing New Wave hadn't really
happened yet synthesizers were in uncool
yet and they did this thing where they
wanted to play music that represented
their time in place and we're known for
these kind of very aggressive live
performances this is a track off their
album their first album and it's called
Ghost Rider
these rather than cycle
these illusions of humans
little jokes
and the last thing is going to be a very
early hip hop so hip hop was this thing
at one point you know hip hop wasn't the
thing that people knew about is just
something had happened at parties and
basements I wasn't yet a worldwide
phenomenon so we thought we couldn't do
music justice we didn't pick this what I
like about hip hop though specifically
is that you'd reached a point in
recorded music where there was so much
prior stuff to sample that you could
make music
clearly out of samples and this this
piece actually has a really great
reference in it which is they take the
keyboard line from a Kraftwerk song it
Kraftwerk is a kind of an amazing early
electronic sort of krautrock band which
is also really good but this this check
this track is pretty awesome
ladies our favorite blast anxious back
to the music yo keep that cover though
so as soon with the 70s nothing happened
the 90s actually some things did happen
the 90s Java happened in the 90s
JavaScript happened in the 90s and we
think there's a really good tune for
this for the fact that these things
happen
I didn't see anyone dancing so that was
a that was a piece by Japanese noise
musician named MERS bow this music was
created and what in his bedroom and and
the cool thing about this is that the
thing about a thing about hip-hop was
that you know so much music had happened
up until that point so they decided to
kind of utilize that in an interesting
way by sampling it and referencing it on
the other side of the coin you had
people that you know understood the fact
that so much music had happened up until
that point that they just wanted to
destroy the actual notion of music
question what is music and what is
organized sound and all of these kinds
of things so similarly around the same
time you have people making programming
languages in in a different context from
the way that they were normally made so
here's a mailing list post from December
in 1995 by Yuka hero Matsumoto and he's
talking about a language that he's
playing with called Ruby and it's you
know meant to replace said and awk and
Perl and you can do some really
interesting things with it and you know
this is a mailing list post on the
Internet
right and and all of the other languages
that we showed you were like academic
papers right so that we thought that
that was really cool and there are a lot
of other examples of this when we
noticed this when David and I were kind
of we collected way more material for
this talk than is actually in the top
and by the time we got to the 90s we're
like all of these languages were
announced on news groups including
Python Perl Ruby closure there was
opposed to a Java mailing list or
something like that so we thought that
that was a really interesting thing to
point out sort of on the end sort of
toward the end of you know this is the
natural consequence of an underground
movement happening is that you know
proliferation of material and things
being easier to use and people having
access to more material means more
better things are produced because more
diverse perspectives are included and so
that was something that we thought that
was really
important to point out so what that's
the end of our mixtape but we wanted to
make sure that we didn't end the talk
without trying to tie it all together a
little bit so I have my own ideas about
so what but what about you David so what
so for me I was you know we when we're
at the end of coming up with this talk
was gonna be about when we sort of saw
the slides and how all the music a a
theme that came up every time we talked
about the material was that as sort of
fans of music you know we both that kind
of agreed that if people just stopped
making music if all composers stopped
making music you could never go through
all the awesome stuff that's been done
in the 20th century it's not possible at
the same time we felt the exact opposite
way with computer programming and
programming languages right it's like no
we can't stop now right it's not time to
stop it's just so much more work to do
and a lot of this is I think in some
sense while recorded music changed the
way we feel about music music is really
old right thousands upon thousands of
years old we don't even know how old it
is so that's my take and yeah and I
think another I think to add a little
bit to what David said so what like if
you think about the infinite amount of
amazing music that has been created by
humans all over the world throughout
history and and the unbelievably rich
tapestry that that creates that's what
we should be striving for when we're
creating programming languages we should
have programming languages that
represent every diverse perspective that
come from every place that are born of
any kind of environment and when we are
able to proliferate these ideas when
we're capable of communicating to people
about what's a programming language all
about why but I want to make a new one
what does that even mean how can I do it
the more people that know that the
better programming will be so we think
that there is a lesson to be learned for
all of us in this in that respect so
that's it
Thanks
you